claude blanchemaison bonjour merci
d'être avec nous cet après midi sur rt
france alors on l'a dit il ya quelques
instants
elle est ministre des affaires
étrangères sont convoqués aujourd'hui
pour discuter de l'élection en
biélorussie et l'europe est elle divisée
sur le sujet et quelle ligne politique
peut-elle adopter sur la sphère de la
biélorussie la situation ensemble
relativement sérieuse puisque les
manifestations se développe dans un an
seulement émise que dans d'autres villes
et puis un certain nombre d'entreprises
ont se sont se sont mises en grève et
que on voit bien que le président le
coach échos qui est au pouvoir depuis 26
ans maintenant qui vient d'être réélu
avec un pourcentage très important mais
en ayant reçu j'ai tous les observateurs
étrangers et en ayant refusé la présence
de journalistes se trouve un petit peu
en difficulté ça ça une obligation à
reprendre le travail est un peu faible
et la question maintenant est de savoir
jusqu'à quel point ils contrôlent
véritablement la situation dans son pays
il a la réputation en effet de gouverné
d'une main de fer mais la question est
de savoir si la situation risque de lui
échapper
dans les prochains jours alors l'union
européenne dans ces circonstances a le
choix entre deux registres le registre
d'un dialogue un peu musclé et
apparemment c'est ce que minsk souhaite
puisqu'il ya un appel du pied de la part
de la présidence biélorusse à une
reprise de ce dialogue critique avec
l'union européenne
c'est un peu une concession mais au
point où on en est et il n'est pas sûr
que cela suffise
et il est possible que l'union
européenne s'achemine vers des sanctions
probablement ciblées
sur l'entourage du président loukachenko
justement je maison je me permets de
vous les délations vous parler des
sanctions un instant c est la présidente
de la commission européenne et qui l'a
annoncé tout à l'heure en début d'après
midi
quelle forme justement pourrait prendre
ces sanctions
bon il est probable que les états
membres qui vont en discuter par
vidéoconférence cet après midi les mises
affaires étrangères vont sans doute
avoir l'idée de recourir à des sanctions
personnelles vis-à-vis du président
loukachenko et de son entourage qui
peuvent toucher à des interdictions de
visas à des restrictions sur la
détention de comptes bancaires à
l'étranger ou des choses du genre mais
évidemment pas des sanctions économiques
qui porterait naturellement préjudice à
la population
cela dit comme vous le savez il ya une
autre réunion dans deux semaines puis
ensuite un conseil européen au mois de
septembre
donc je pense que les ministres des
affaires étrangères cet après midi vont
rester prudents pour pouvoir évaluer
dans quelle situé dans quel sens sa
situation évolue sur place la présidence
biélorusse s'est dit favorable à un
dialogue avec les pays étrangers
ce matin qu'est ce que les pays
étrangers peuvent concrètement faire
pour la biélorussie aujourd'hui
l'attitude de l'union européenne était
déjà celle à un dialogue critique avec
avec minsk et ceux ci comportent en
effet un certain nombre de discussions
sur la façon de maintenir l'ordre dans
le dans l'est dans le pays de réprimer
les manifestations sur le respect des
droits de l'homme et notamment le
respect des libertés pour les
journalistes et on voit bien aujourd'hui
l'écho que recueille madame tikhonov sky
à l'opposante
aux dernières élections qui n'a fait
certes que 10% mais naturellement la
façon dont ces élections se sont
déroulées est mise en question par une
bonne partie de la population du pays
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
les manifestations sont de plus en plus
nombreuses en biélorussie de plus en
plus de secteurs professionnels se
mettent en grève ces derniers temps est
ce que la rue peut avoir raison du
gouvernement local shinko alors
apparemment mal habillés comme sky at il
ya beaucoup à ce que c'est
ces manifestations restent pacifiques et
qu'elle s'exprime par notamment le fait
que les femmes qui manifestent soit
habillé en blanc et qu' il n'y ait pas
de violence du côté des manifestants il
y a déjà des violences du côté de la
police il y en a eu mais aussi et ça
c'est ça qui leur est véritablement
inquiétant pour pour le pouvoir quelques
policiers qui manifestement ont fait
défection alors on pense que le
président de le président qui vient
d'être réélu contrôle parfaitement les
forces armées mais dans le fond c'est là
que les choses vont se jouer sur le
comportement de la police et des
militaires merci beaucoup claude
blanchemaison d'avoir été avec nous cet
après midi je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales
merci beaucoup